on va revenir sur toutes les rigolades
qui sont sortis sur ce discours alors
c'est vrai que les gens réagissent et
sur la barre d'histoire flip le pauvre
ça franchement ça fait de la peine parce
que je pense que je pense que ces moyens
je vous dis la vérité pourquoi je pense
que c'est le stress voilà et c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de fans là
dessus voilà mais c'est vrai alors si
donc s'il ya eu un blush un plein de
tweets extrêmement drôle notamment on va
faire une revue de tweets notamment
celui de king et king air qui dit voilà
qui twitte donc edouard philippe
et qui dit avant de commencer je vais
être clair la bande de ce grec qui fait
du diabolo tous les dimanches après vos
buttes chaumont pour divertir enguerrand
et marie clothilde si je vous revois là
bas je vous goom edouard philippe
voilà ça c'est après voilà c'est bien
sûr en rapport avec ces images du xviiie
arrondissement qu'on avait vu voulez les
revoir ces images
regardez c'est aussi en rapport avec ces
images là à regarder ça va arriver
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
voilà c'était une vanne par rapport à ça
bien entendu oui jean michel meyer oui
oui on se moque souvent on se moque on
remarque souvent la barre à peu de
dépigmenter de edouard philippe
mais franchement moi j'en ai marre on se
pose toujours des politiques je pense
aux ronces ayessa d'accord avec morgue
non c'est plus des pourris sans sa place
et franchement c'est un sacerdoce et
homme politique s'il à la barbe blanche
et y perd ses cheveux et ses terrasses
parce que ça stresse il se donne corps
et âme à son métier c'est un métier de
ouf hommes politiques on prend les
responsabilités on en prend plein la
gueule
franchement si vous laissez faire de
l'argent un autre métier avocat mina el
rhazoui jeu défouler sur l'hermétique
non maman david guilluy à mon avis veut
faire sauter des contraventions un truc
comme ça c'est parce qu'il adore une
contravention il a dû avoir une prune à
prix correct je vais jeter à faire
sauter je les regarde avec oui il ya
plein de gens ce moment qu'il y jean
michel maire ou l'adorent mais c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment le confinement laon
dieu plus mais bon c'est pas grave mais
question et je vous dise et laurent
seigne on pouvait pas dire le contraire
après mois voilà alors il ya eu il ya eu
plein de tweets je vous dis extrêmement
drôle s'il ya eu celui là notamment
celui de haddad 12,66 donc et c'est une
discussion entre emmanuel macron et
edouard philippe donc edouard philippe
lui dis bon thé chaud rajoute un mois
[ __ ] me chauffe pas aidé ou le poil à
noter sur le hamois de raffinement le
premier ministre pose une question
regarder si je fais revenir sam dans koh
lanta peut-être qu'ils arrêteront de me
casser les couilles
voilà ça c'est d'la balle part ça il y
en a qui ont charrié la longueur du
discours aussi à skip son discours et
dure jusqu'au 11 mai ses lunes et la
cani ça très drôle si d'autres noms
d'autres n'ont pas l'air d'avoir qui
fait de discours edouard philippe versus
aux éoliennes qui brasse le plus de
l'air edouard philippe tf1 voilà hashtag
payer une phrase du discours qui a fait
énormément rigoler des tweetos le virus
pourrait disparaître sans raison donc là
ils ont mis la tête du virus regarder il
est tranquille dans la vraie vie
tranquille il va disparaître voilà les
russies une annonce des quinze élèves
match par slash et interagir pas plus de
15 élèves par classe
nous quand on sera pas dans le même
groupe que nos potes regarder avec la
photo voilà
yahi douar philippe pas plus de 15
élèves par classe ou quand on sera pas
dans un groupe que nos potes voilà aussi
voilà c'est très bon et celui qui a fait
le buzz bien entendu pendant ce discours
et je pense qu'il a fait exprès qu'il
avait qui prévu c'est bien sûr jean luc
mélenchon il a fait énormément réagir la
tête de jean luc mélenchon regardez le
gars a l'air de s'en [ __ ] mais
royalement du discours du premier
ministre
ça par contre je vous dis c'est sûr que
c'est une posture c'est vraiment qu'il a
dû préparer ça avant franchement voilà
un peu relou regardez au prix d'une
déprogrammation des opérations
chirurgicales non nécessaires à court
terme mais qui finiront bien par lettre
le risque d'une seconde vague qui
viendrait frapper un tissu hospitalier
fragilisées qui fait on truquer bas a
relevé jean milhau et rom et et le voilà
à les gens me jean midi à ton chien
d'aller te plaît il ya son chien qui
gratte
tu veux que j'appelle mes chansons non
il gratte pas et gratte avec ses
chaussures qui tous
il décédera en taille énorme études en
magasin à c'était ben haïm et parlez pas
de là tous bouchés donc jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon voilà qui a
été quelques minutes après le discours
d' edouard philippe
c'est au tour de jean luc mélenchon de
prendre la parole mais au moment
surligner son discours le patron de la
faf insoumise emploie le mot j'achève
est là le président de l'assemblée
nationale doc richard ferrand s'est
permis une petite vanne qui a fait
énormément parler regarde est devenu un
événement biologique
il devient un événement économique il
sera un événement social
maintenant avec des millions de chômeurs
et pour finir ce sera un événement
politique
nous n'échapperons pas à cet
enchaînement puisse la patrie qui mis un
euro sur la valeur des mots j'achève
souveraineté indépendance relocalise à
12 h service public c'est nous vous
achevez saluer d'un petit acte mais
c'est vrai que jean luc mélenchon voilà
vous avez vu son attitude si vous en
pensez il renaît qu'est ce tu penses de
ça même si on veut pas qu'on fait parce
politique à nos jeunes et déjà reçu moi
je gère mélenchon yara car il ou de
révision de gak petit paco pour moi que
tu m'as pas mort
la barre et voilà il et il a bien mangé
pendant trente ans avec parti socialiste
m stephen âmes comme à sa maman moi
c'est une estrade
ils se croient tous nouvelle j'aime pas
vrai